Candice is with us in st. Louis hi
Candace how are you hi baby Ramsey how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I am in $200,000 and that student loans
oh I haven't even finished college and
right now I am working a minimum job
I mean minimum wage job and I'm just
trying to get a hold of my life right
now so I'm just trying to get some
guidance at this point what were you
doing going two hundred thousand dollars
in debt well I was going school for
filming video and at first I was for
interior designed and I transferred to a
different school for filming video so
that's pretty much the schools that I
work that I was going to were out of
state good lord
yeah and I'm not gonna not bother you
that you were running up that much dad I
mean how did you that your mother I went
to school right out of high school and
my parents they didn't know much about
you know financing or at least they
didn't teach me anything about it they
just told me that I'll have these
student loans and I had to take them
back and I really wasn't conscious of
you know student loans in that sense so
how much do you like before you graduate
I have only like a year left and I want
to go back to school to get my degree
Yeah right now I just want to at least
try to take the big chunk out of the
student loans at least a little bit of
it yeah well you don't you know you're
not gonna do that make a minimum wage
obviously you're bad you're barely
eating making it how old are you I'm 28
this is another thing that I am working
on so
I am working on a movie and I'm putting
my money that work into the movie into
the movie and I also have sponsorships
that's helping to fund the movie and I
also have a partnership as well and so
I'm just taking a leap of faith that
this movie will bring a substantial
amount of money what makes you think
that it's a faith in I believe the
storyline it's a good storyline and it's
a good content to cover I mean do you
know anything about distributing a movie
and monetizing it well this is the thing
I mean it's an independent movie and I
know that my partner he is going to help
you know with any of the funds that we
need in order to get it to where we need
to go basically you know he's it's
basically his faith into my project
that's that's how okay I want to see you
live your dream and I want to see the
movie be produced and and get out there
but I'm also duty-bound as your old ugly
uncle to tell you the truth and that is
is that you have a pattern since you're
20 years old of entering into things and
not carrying what they cost and not
knowing what you're getting into
I mean the movie business is a
rough-and-tumble business independence
that the independent movies they go out
there and make big money are almost none
right you're got to be aware of that
yeah I'm aware I'm totally aware of oh
you can't you know you can't listen I'm
a person of faith but there's there's
faith and then there's just dreaming and
so I want you to have a solid business
plan by which your faith is executed and
my partner is going to put some money
into it and get it where
needs to go that's not a business plan
the movies yeah movies get made every
day that nobody sees that's true and
lots of independent movies get made
every day that nobody sees and I'm okay
with you working on your dream but you
you've got to start entering into things
whether it's your continuation of your
education whether it's the time you're
spending on this movie the money you're
spending on this movie or whatever it is
you've got to start entering into things
with your eyes more open and just going
oh we're just going to start this and
it'll all work out because maybe it
hasn't been working out and if you
submit let's say you let's say you spend
two years on this movie and you get zip
out of it
oh no I'm not spending two years I don't
go ahead but I mean that that's you know
you've got to have a an understanding of
the behind the scenes part of how a
movie gets launched and how it turns
into money that you don't have today
otherwise you can't spend your time on
it and because it's not dream anymore
it's it becomes a nightmare like you're
going to school it was your parents
dream for you to go school but nobody
thought about what you were spending on
that schooling and so you've gotten
yourself in an absurd scenario with
$200,000 in student loan debt working a
minimum-wage job it's just a horrible
place to be for you darling I just feel
so bad for you so I want you to start
things in your life that you can see in
detail how they can occur and that is
faith - that's wisdom is what it is and
wisdom goes with faith and so step by
step by step how am I going to get my
career rolling actually make some money
a high probability of making some money
not one shot in the dark which is really
what a movie is it's one shot in the
dark and I don't mind you working on
that but that probably ought to be your
side gig while you work on something
else that makes you some money and you
get over there finish your degree and
then you get out there making 50 60 80
100 1250 thousand you know you get
yourself a career track going kiddo so
you can get this mess cleaned up and you
can live a life because right now you've
got this this monstrous oppression over
the top of your head
of this debt I'm so sad for you I wish I
could just wave a wand and make it go
away but what I want to hear you what I
want you to hear and I want you to hear
it me loving you and not saying I'm not
a dream killer I'm not a dream stealer
but I am somebody that tries to prevent
nightmares from occurring and right now
you got a nightmarish occurrence with a
student loan debt and if you don't
develop a detailed plan on how this
movie turns into money and you keep
working on it you're entering into
another nightmare so you need to have a
pattern where you what Stephen Covey
said in the books the seven Habits of
Highly Effective People is you you begin
with the end in mind
and it's not just I'm gonna make this
movie and I have faith it's gonna make
me a bazillion dollars that that those
are words that that indicate you don't
know what you're doing and you need to
go find what you're doing and that's
that's when you put wisdom and faith
together and as you start doing those
things you're gonna see some differences
I'm not trying to hurt your feelings and
it's not my goal here I'm trying to love
you well kiddo while you're here on the
air with me so I want you to go through
our class Financial Peace University
since I picked on you and I picked on
you for your own good but I want you to
go through the nine week class I will
pay for it I'm gonna give it to you for
free because you need some good people
in your life to gather around you and
help you walk through this that can see
the end in mind with you as far as the
this being this debt and getting your
money under control and really getting
your career on track too so I'll tell
you all so Kelly when we pick up and you
give her a Financial Peace University
also give her the book start and Candice
I want you to read that book as soon as
it comes in the mail once you sit down
that day and read that book it won't
take you that long it's a quick read and
it'll really help you get your arms
around what I'm talking about where you
lay out a plan a roadmap to go towards
being awesome and I want you to be
awesome I want you to win but um you
know you have to that book you know
start takes you through that roadmap
it's what it does and it'll help you do
that so hang on Kelly I'll pick up and
we'll get you in Financial Peace
University and get you that book and if
I can help you all your fighting through
all this you call me I'll walk with you
I'm on your team I'm not here to kill
your dreams I'm here to keep from
turning keep them from turning then
tonight
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]